welcome to the QuickStart tutorial for
manage kubernetes today we're going to
deploy a containerized application first
we'll need to enable the kubernetes
engine API on our project in the
navigation menu click on API and
services and then click enable api's and
services here search for kubernetes
engine and select it from the results on
the kubernetes engine API page click
enable to enable it on the project next
let's activate the cloud shell in our
console where we'll run our commands
once we're here we can specify the
default zone that we want the G cloud
and cube cuttle commands to use type G
cloud config set compute zone followed
by a zone for this demonstration let's
use US East 1 with our default zone set
let's create a kubernetes cluster a
cluster consists of at least one cluster
master and multiple worker machines
called nodes these nodes are compute
engine VMs that run the kubernetes
processes an application is deployed to
a cluster and runs on its nodes enter
the command G cloud container clusters
create and a cluster name once our
cluster is created
we'll need authentication credentials to
interact with it we'll get that with G
cloud container clusters get credentials
followed by the cluster name the get
credentials sub command will configure
queue cuddle the command-line interface
for running commands against kubernetes
clusters to use the cluster we just
created in any subsequent commands now
it's time to deploy a containerized
application to our cluster type cube
cuddle create deployment and a name for
our deployment let's go with hello
server
we provided a sample web application
called hello app we can specify its
google container registry URL with the -
- image tag our application is deployed
but if we want to see what it looks like
we'll need to expose it to the Internet
by creating a kubernetes service type
cube cuddle expose deployment followed
by our deployment name
hello server we'll specify a type load
bouncer a port 80 and a target port 8080
this means that the load balancer will
initialize the public port 80 to the
Internet and route traffic to port 8080
of the application after a few minutes
the load balancer should be all set up
and have an assigned external IP address
cube cuddle get serviced followed by our
deployment name will show us the IP
address we'll use to access our
application enter that IP address in a
new tab or window and there you have it
leads just deployed a containerized web
application to kubernetes
you
[Music]